we are now about to eat dinner and not
just any dinner what kind of dinner yeah
super and entertainment with
[Music]
all right so this is the highlight of
the trip we're about to get on our camel
ride and then we're going to spend the
night in the desert I'm so excited this
is totally exactly what I imagined like
this met my expectations it actually
exceeded my expectation so beautiful I'm
trying not to cover you with my head the
stereotypical like image in my head of
traveling the world is to come to a
place like this
now we've traveled the world yeah oh no
I I still want to see like snowy stuff
so this is like our desert chilly camels
once it's its little piece in the vlog -
he's like smiling oh you gotta go about
the ride your buddy you're ready baby
wearing a screen favorite grana
screensaver right now you know riding
these camels I'm excited nervous [ __ ]
you you're nervous I'm always nervous
right
to melt
[Music]
riding a camel today that's right we're
riding camels for the next two days this
is wild
hey buddy my legs feel so short camels
do smell a little bit though looks like
very very peaceful wanna just touch the
sand now
[Music]
20 is 10 line in my ankle it's like the
inverted wrist the the watched an all
right this has got to be one of the most
amazing experiences I have ever had in
my life
Ryan a camel in the Sahara Desert I must
do on your bucket list that's checked
off check
to get to our campsite as wonderful as
his ride was I'm not gonna lie it really
starts to hurt after about 15 minutes
does it hurt you are you hanging in
there buddy we're almost there
you look like wow oh my legs thank you
for the ride oh we hurt doesn't it
like right here around my inner thigh it
is it's like the beach except there's no
water like we find Oh Lester this is way
better than the beach show you you're
dead
we get a couple of quarters no it's warm
in here it is well there's a light you
have light yeah that's very cool leave
the energy though okay neighbors we can
hear each other perfectly through the
walls so cool we get to stay in a Berber
campsite so it's like a different race
of people that are here in Morocco they
speak a different language too and our
tour guide is River himself so we get to
stay in one of the cat sites pretty
awesome it's really hot in here
alright go catch a sunset right now at
the top of that dude the top of the dune
there we go you're gonna get yourself so
tired before we even start
oh my goodness huh this is tough how do
the camels do it like I love this I love
this hard line right here I want to roll
down this thing going to then when we
get back yeah we're gonna get Santa
everywhere how are you we gotta get over
the this this hairy right here Fred that
we literally just started as the
altitude yeah run
that's so fun huh this is amazing view
this is an experience you know the
Padilla that we've been eating every day
very not healthy for you
this is the perfect cardio for that burn
all that misty off all right we made it
how long did it take us to get up here
it doesn't matter we made it
[Music]
it was like the sunset every ready meat
the journey back down yeah easy on the
moon shower tomorrow oh yeah
so pretty I could already feel like
cooling down a lot
[Music]
[Music]
it's obviously anyway like I try to feel
sexy and that comes up like a fail never
fell with you hey you said it never felt
like going back on your word
[Music]
oh is that fun I'm dizzy oh my gosh
there's so much sand in the back of your
head oh my mouth show Quran everybody
dinners a pitch biking I'm you know
alright it's bedtime there we go
[Music]
I know anyone want to take my makeup off
or anything I'm like what's the point
you have allergy to really kicking in
after sleeping outdoors
I feel my boogers boogers aren't
pleasant either there's a lot of sand in
there somewhere in Africa we up side by
side hey neighbor
ah they're beating us speed up cancel
stay up did you come from King Apollo
high school
[Music]
all right all showered ready to eat
great now I know we're feeling all I got
here yeah from this band let's get out
of here head back to civilization
not really I think we're going to a
village partial civilization yeah that
was impressive for a split second
because you kept it up you're juggling
[Music]
all these our hotels
in 30 years
like road
hotels like not happy really
area out here are bagging
[Music]
where are we now we're in the boards in
the gorgeous
Morocco is a beautiful country all right
so TIFF where's the zit
why doesn't that know where's is that
the name of this place a legend of that
so this place is known for cinema this
is like the Hollywood of Morocco yeah I
was not we're gonna check out where they
film gladiator
it's a unicycle World Heritage Site I'll
tell you what it's called later because
I remember what it's called right now
[Music]
there is gladiator movie when he was a
slave to become gladiator that was the
arena you can see the arena the first
Ave know how to make tan Jean I hate
cooking instead of paprika turmeric red
garlic ginger pepper salt and cumin
onion first
[Music]
cuz everything's already prepped for you
yeah I know he has a cleanup at later
yeah she added a little water and we mix
it all up
make sure all the spices get all of them
there and then we need it to cook the
reason why the water is important it so
the oil doesn't burn to make it taste
nasty my wife is cooking
I want to be so bad about to get excited
hope it came out good good is it better
than all the restaurants I like it my
own face on my cheek that's right
let me go home we're gonna be making
this for me right yeah that's a solid
yeah so this is our last full day on
this trip tomorrow morning we leave so
right now we're heading towards
Marrakesh and this has been the windiest
road ever because you have to get
through the mountains and I'm trying so
hard not to vomit but this is a
beautiful view all right we are now at a
McDonald's and Marrakesh
so we're gonna join a tour to go see the
medina here in Marrakech
it only has a small amount of time to
eat so we can in McDonald if we wanted
to come to McDonald's anyways because we
wanted to try a Moroccan McDonald's to
have the thing convict Arabia here so
we're gonna do that right now
sauce is pretty good it's a hamburger
and a PITA everything but the meat is
like a big magnet feet up Marrakech is a
breath of nice breath fresh air because
it's so nice breakfast yeah it's breath
a nice breath no it's so much more
different than all the other more rural
areas we've been in it's got more of the
metropolitan kind of vibe out here
Heights France but the Moroccan version
yeah play in the McDonald's yeah the
other McDonald's there was no English
options over L is like what McDonald
thought it'd been out of English be I
was only French or Arabic I thought that
was kind of cool the whole menu was
pretty much the same McDonald that we've
had in France it was not a lot of
it's just from this grave yet true yeah
the way French and Arabic are used here
it seems like it's like how English and
Spanish is used in the states where it's
like those are their top two options for
languages and then everything else kind
of falls to the wayside
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we just got to London this is our
very tiny cute adorable hotel room it's
so tiny we're staying at the airport
because we leave first thing in the
morning super early in the morning so we
have to make the most out of the little
time we have here in London and we're
gonna try to go eat right now we'll
check out the London I go check out Big
Ben the Buckingham Palace and that's
pretty much all I know about London and
that's all I kind of want to see and
then I don't know we're gonna try to get
lost and see what else would bump into
and the short amount of time we have
yeah we're gonna go eat now
[Music]
I got the first order if it's and anyone
is to get a pint of beer at a pub
I don't know like what do you recommend
she was like this one's a winner no all
right let's go over that one this is the
winner
[Music]
makes it go healthier right on the
please healthy it's good but I like I
love it when ever you could you I try to
do vibrato for your voice no yeah we're
obviously feeling really good after
those two plane traffic yeah it's always
on the left side yeah did you I was
looking that way I know right now we're
gonna get right over here
[Music]
that's what it really looks like inside
and that's so fun
[Music]
now that I've proved myself great he
kept saying that the Big Ben was the
tower that would make more sense I'm
like no it's under construction they
even had headlines all over the place
that they're gonna be closing Big Ben
for a long time and it's the one that
has the scaffolding I kept telling you
you wouldn't listen him you're like no I
don't think so it's that what men
[Music]
world Harry Potter's world like Mary
Poppins world then bedroom 63 much 50%
everybody you grew up with pretty much
enjoy it extra for him we're only here
for like less than 24 hours so we're
gonna do a proper the next time we're
here we're gonna bring Isaac definitely
he needs to come with
[Music]
you're gonna ticket office to get at our
actual barcode the ticket outflows and
they just told us right now like you
have the email and I'll show you here
the screenshot of the confirmation she
was like I need something this panel
like no please I promise they did pay
for that my promise though they try to
pull up the email less than issue they
just go just go
I'm like
[Music]
TV erial screen savers and so we're
always flying you through here but now
we're actually here at this time it's
pretty cool then especially because I
remember always thinking about this play
smells a little Perl and always wishing
like
sort of
[Music]
actually see the lightning I've never
seen that before in my life
see the clouds moving in with the
lightning that's so cool in LA you only
see lightning maybe like one and like
never on them yeah no just walking
through London at 10 p.m. it's a Sunday
today and everything seems to be closing
so they're not too sure what to do or
where to go but we might as well go to
Buckingham Palace real quick check that
out and then find a pub I still open I
don't know do puffs those are only on
Sundays here cuz we walked by a couple
pubs that were already closed the idea
was to go Buckingham Palace and then
maybe he had a bite to eat and a drink
add another pub feel so cool saying the
word pub in the States would go
bar-hopping over here from what I
understand it's pub crawling
[Music]
alright back at the hotel it's a really
cool lighting right now is our hotel has
some really unique lighting that's like
super high-end like upscale kind of
decor I guess you know like a rich guy
like a rich bachelor it's like a
bachelor pad because the soap it even
smells like on my hand like a like
Cologne that's the kind of hotel you
think a lot of business guys would bring
like a friend packed at a room that's
what it feels like in here it's so dark
in here the lighting is really dark Lee
this is all life that trend huh yeah
that's true
mm-hmm I brought my friend back in here
oh right right all right anyways we've
got airport food since our hotel is at
the airport guys I'm so smart I decided
to book the hotel at the airport since
our flight is so early in the morning I
was like oh no let's not worry about
booking a hotel in the city and then
worrying about coming into the airport
early early early in the morning because
we don't know traffic or any of that
stuff that is why I booked the hotel
here it's really nice I really liked it
I liked how this bathroom
the showers right here and then toilets
right there everything is one in the
same pretty cool so that means if Hubert
a shower your toilet and your sink is
probably get wet whole place to get away
well just just texted me wishing chicken
oozing what is she saying
Oh cute miss you your trip looks super
cool because they're having fun Thank
You Jess but yeah so this is the end of
our first leg yes the end of the trip
that of our first trip planned together
because the Croatia part came later so
that's the reason why we're flying back
to Los Angeles tomorrow and then we're
gonna be there for I think what six
hours eight hours yeah and then we fly
off to Croatia yeah you know what's
crazy is we packed enough clothes for us
to extend our ourselves to Croatia
without ever having to go home once we
get back to three weeks but we
recalculated our hours in LA
I think we can make it back home and
things are I thinks all the souvenirs
that we bought and then all the dirty
clothes and then just stuff clean
clothes yeah and basically lessen the
load because we've been caring like
everyone else on a Morocco trip had like
a backpack and I was it and we're the
only ones with like two suitcases per
person plus like a backpack and so we
would be looked like the bourgeois
people of the group but which wasn't the
case we just had a really long trip
ahead of us but uh so yeah so that's
what's gonna happen tomorrow mm-hmm so
we should eat we have warm food oh yeah
which yeah
miss find out that warm anymore we
talked a while yeah oh my god are we
telling about the drone no
[Music]